[Música]
hola bienvenidos a aqui américa el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente yo soy natalia
cabrera parada y esto es lo que veremos
hoy
empezamos en el sur en chile que sigue
dando pasos para eliminar la
constitución heredada de la dictadura
militar el presidente gabriel boric
recibió el borrador formal de la nueva
carta magna que deberá ser aprobada en
un plebiscito en septiembre y ya
comenzaron las campañas a favor y en
contra les contamos desde santiago
y nos quedamos aquí en el sur en ecuador
porque una organización de mujeres
indígenas está trabajando para detener
las agresiones contra ellas por parte de
sus parejas la violencia machista en la
provincia de morona santiago aumentó un
79 por ciento en el último año y vamos
al norte del continente donde iniciaron
las vacaciones de verano los jóvenes
canadienses se preparan para ingresar al
mercado laboral con empleos temporales
pero algunos sindicatos advierten que
contratar a adolescentes podría tener
consecuencias perversas
y vamos de inmediato a chile porque
iniciaron las campañas a favor y en
contra de la nueva carta magna del país
que será votada en un plebiscito el 4 de
septiembre si es aprobado el texto
reemplazaría a la constitución heredada
de la dictadura de augusto pinochet y en
la que entre otros cambios propuestos
está calificar a chile como un estado
social y democrático y el reconocimiento
de 11 grupos indígenas nuestra
corresponsal en santiago patricia luna
nos explica que se espera de esta
campaña
tras la entrega el pasado lunes del
texto de la nueva constitución al
presidente gabriel boric por parte de la
convención constitucional esta semana se
inició en chile- oficialmente la campaña
a favor de la prueba y el rechazo
mientras que el rechazo se manifiesta en
pancartas a las salidas del metro y se
ha centrado sobre todo en una campaña
digital que encabeza el ex oficialismo
de sebastián piñera chile vamos y
también el partido republicano de jose
antonio kast la
izquierda los movimientos sociales y
algunos ex convencionales
constitucionales se congregaron el día
del lanzamiento de la campaña para
formar una figura hermana con forma de a
a favor de la prueba esto en un chile
bastante por ali polarizado en el que
los últimos días son varios las figuras
de la centroizquierda que se han
cuadrado de forma sorpresiva a favor del
rechazo mientras que en el ambiente
todavía continúa la polémica generada
por la carta del ex presidente ricardo
lagos una de las figuras más influyentes
del mundo político en chile que afirmó
que ni el actual texto presentado por la
convención constitucional ni la
constitución de 1980 que rige en la
actualidad y que data de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet ha logrado consensos en
la ciudadanía chilena y por tanto el
debate tiene que continuar hasta que se
logren acuerdos más transversales de
forma también sorpresiva la democracia
cristiana un partido histórico en chile
pero que ha venido perdiendo influencia
en los últimos años se cuadró a favor
del apruebo esto es la situación
mientras que las encuestas se marcan una
clara tendencia a favor del rechazo
51-49 dependiendo de la encuesta frente
al 31 34 a favor de la prueba en las
últimas encuestas acortan esta distancia
a 46 a favor del chacho 41 a favor de la
prueba la incógnita es lo que van a
votar los 15 millones de chilenos muchos
de ellos aún indecisos que se espera que
en estos dos meses que aun quedan de
campaña pueda conocer más profundamente
el texto constitucional y dar una voto
informado en las urnas el próximo 4 de
octubre
patricia luna nuestra corresponsal en
santiago gracias por la información y
vamos a quedarnos aquí en el sur del
continente porque la provincia
ecuatoriana de morona santiago en la
amazonía de ese país es la más violenta
para las mujeres según cifras de la red
de mujeres amazónicas las agresiones
aumentaron un 79 por ciento entre los 21
y 2022 nuestro corresponsal gustavo
ortega se trasladó hasta allí y nos
cuenta la historia de las activistas
amazónicas que luchan por conseguir un
lugar más seguro para las mujeres
indígenas raúl siria está a cargo de su
hija anna ahora postrada en cama luego
de ser rescatada al borde de una vida
tras sufrir una agresión por su pareja
anna forma parte de las estadísticas de
la corte de justicia regional de la
provincia de morona santiago la ciudad
más violenta de ecuador para las mujeres
indígenas donde en 2021 se registraron
mil 252 delitos sexuales tuvo un derrame
cerebral por el golpe que tenía en la
nuca entonces queda en vegetal ahorita
está cinco meses y necesitamos apoyo
realmente
un básico es alimento y es el más básico
79 de cada 100 mujeres de la amazonía
son víctimas de violencia de género la
mayoría viven aisladas y no saben a
dónde acudir lo que agrava el escenario
según las defensoras de derechos las
consecuencias embarazos en niñas
matrimonios forzados abuso y explotación
sexual de vidrios y violencia física
es el caso de auxilio quien también
sufrió y ahora lucha para proteger a las
mujeres indígenas
reclamamos nosotros inversión también
para lo que es el tema de la prevención
atención y erradicación de las
violencias que superponen a la amazonía
con dos puntos porcentuales superiores
al promedio país
promedio el que también se encuentra en
abril a chicas quien logró escapar de su
agresor que era su propio padrastro
abandonada por su madre e historiada por
su familia huyó con una de sus hijas hoy
vive en extrema pobreza
yo viví
como una esclava
abusado de ese señor
y halagos
a los 12 12 años me quedé embarazada de
primera
la asignación de recursos en el
presupuesto general del estado para
atender la violencia en contra de las
mujeres de la amazonía es marginal sin
embargo auxilio no se doblega en su
misión de conseguir más protección por
ello demanda crear un fondo común anual
con un porcentaje no menor a el 15%
financiado por las regalías de la renta
petrolera y recursos naturales
visitamos eeuu direct show bin el
policía blanco que ya cumplía una
sentencia de 22 años por el asesinato de
georg floyd fue ahora sentenciado a más
de 20 años de prisión por violar los
derechos civiles del joven afroamericano
la sentencia dead es parte de un acuerdo
en el que se declaró además culpable de
violar los derechos de otro joven de 14
años durante un arresto en 2017 las dos
sentencias se ejecutarán simultáneamente
y chauvín será trasladado a una prisión
federal el asesinato de georg floyd
desató una ola de protestas contra el
racismo estructural en la unión
americana que fue replicada en varios
países en donde se manifestó con el
derribo de estatua de la era colonial no
obstante estos hechos siguen
presentándose las celebraciones del día
de la independencia el 4 de julio se
vieron eclipsadas en ohio debido a las
protestas por el asesinato de un
afroestadounidense desarmado la policía
le disparó al menos 60 veces
james walker es de 25 años evadió un
intento de parada de tráfico el 27 de
junio
las imágenes de la cámara corporal
publicadas por el departamento de
policía de akrón muestran lo que sucedió
en los momentos siguientes se hicieron
varios disparos incluso después de que
lleguen walker cayera al suelo
no no sabemos el número exacto de veces
que se disparos según el vídeo tiempo
que ese número será alto se disparó
muchas veces en el momento del tiroteo
estaba desarmado la policía en el lugar
dice que creyó que yo gran disparo desde
el interior de su automóvil antes de
huir del vehículo y que era una amenaza
potencial
[Música]
quieren convertirlo en un monstruo
enmascarado con un arma lo sabíamos
ayuda
pero quiero agradecerle al jefe de la
policía lo que dijo
en el momento en el que dispararon más
de 90 ó 60 cualquiera que sea el
increíble número de veces
el nombre will be
él estaba desarmado
estamos cansados de morir así de esta
manera de esta forma es feliz
las protestas estallaron en akrón
después de que se publicara en las
imágenes de la cámara corporal policial
durante la muerte de yoilán walker esto
incitó a las autoridades locales a
cancelar los fuegos artificiales del 4
de julio e imponer un toque de queda
temporal en el centro el asesinato de
walker ahora está siendo investigado por
el fiscal general de ohio y la oficina
de investigación criminal del estado los
ocho oficiales involucrados en el
tiroteo han sido puestos en licencia
administrativa el caso es el más
reciente que involucra a un hombre negro
desarmado asesinado a manos de la
policía en eeuu para que sea el último
activista surgen a tomar medidas contra
el racismo estructural
vámonos a canadá donde las vacaciones de
verano ya comenzaron y es la perfecta
ocasión para que algunos jóvenes se
estrenen en el mercado laboral
especialmente a raíz del aumento de
vacantes surgida durante la pandemia de
coronavirus en canadá donde es legal el
trabajo de menores de edad las empresas
dependen cada vez más de los jóvenes lo
que es motivo de preocupación para
algunos nuestros corresponsales nos
enviaron el siguiente informe
una vez que termina la escuela por las
vacaciones de verano
anthony hace turnos en esta tienda en
montreal al trabajo de 20 a 25 horas a
la semana ayuda a la gente a empacar las
compras sacó la basura anthony tiene
sólo 14 años en quebec no existe una
edad mínima para trabajar
quería trabajar desde que era un niño
pequeña para comprarme cosas y ahorrar
dinero para mi futuro
mis padres me impulsan y me ayudan a
lograrlo es un gran negocio para su
director que ha tenido dificultades para
contratar personal este año en mayo
tuvimos dificultades para encontrar
gente pero está mejorando antes tenían
16 17 años cuando solicitaron el trabajo
pero la sociedad cambia los niños de 11
12 años se sienten cómodos manejando el
teléfono y las computadoras ahora en
abril la tasa de desempleo de quebec
cayó a un mínimo histórico de sólo el 4%
la provincia atraviesa escasez de mano
de obra la contratación de adolescentes
es una solución pero los sindicatos
dicen que podría hacer riesgosas que las
reglas no son lo suficientemente
estrictas en este momento la ley permite
que un empleador abusivo por ejemplo que
los niños de 11 a 14 años trabajen
demasiadas horas sacador
para el sociólogo james conseguir un
trabajo de verano podría ser bueno para
adolescentes pero también podría
conducir a una mayor tasa de abandono
escolar y
ayuda al trabajador joven a socializar
ya conocer pero el problema es
especialmente aquí en quebec que
demasiados jóvenes ya están abandonando
la escuela antes de tiempo
y eso podría convertirse en una
preocupación cada vez mayor para los más
jóvenes y niños otra señal de que los
adolescentes han inundado el mercado
laboral el año pasado un mayor número de
accidentes de trabajo entre los mayores
de 16 años y me despido con la cifra de
la semana 63 esa es la cantidad de
perros calientes o hot docs que comió
joey chestnut en el famoso concurso
anual de comer perros calientes del 4 de
julio en la ciudad de night and ese es
el número mágico que le trajo su
victoria en número 15 y como si eso no
fuera suficiente espectáculo también
puso a un manifestante que interrumpe la
competencia bajo una llave de
estrangulamiento mientras continuaba
comiendo
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa pueden ver esta emisión
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que viene en su pantalla y
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]
nuestros